de la joie du soulagement pour les
handballeuses de montigny le bretonneux
pour leur premier match de la saison
elles se sont imposés 32 à 28 face au
psg ce samedi 14 septembre au gymnase
pierre de coubertin
une rencontre mal débuté par les
inimités début est difficile
dur de rentrer dedans après
c'est vrai que toute équipe a été pas
vraiment dedans mais on a réussi quand
même à dire est resté soudé et de faire
une bonne deuxième mi-temps quoi le
couac il a parlé dans un vestiaire menés
sur le score de 14 à 17 à la mi temps
brahim sadi nouvel entraîneur des
féminines de montigny le bretonneux
donne des consignes pour relancer son
équipe face à la ténacité des
parisiennes les yvelinoises réussissent
à prendre le score
elle ne le lâcheront pas jusqu'à la fin
de la partie en deuxième mi temps on a
essayé de justement corriger ça aux
vestiaires donc on a demandé justement
d'être plus agressives en défense d'être
vus compacts ils travaillaient ensemble
sur un bloc et c'est ce qui nous a
réussi donc on a eu assez l'efficacité
qu'on n'a pas eues en première mi temps
nos objectifs déjà on est en train de
construire un groupe qui est solide on a
essayé d'oeuvre en a eu des départs on a
on a dû recrues il faut que la
mayonnaise prenne donc on joue un match
par match
un nouveau projet de jeu mis en place
par l'entraîneur avec la volonté d'avoir
une continuité dans le travail à
l'entraînement pour la deuxième journée
les inhumant ten se déplace à
aulnay-sous-bois ce dimanche 22
septembre à 16 heures
[Musique]